hey how you doing this is Mel strong and
this lecture is on temperature
inversions and air pollution and we're
going to start by looking at the
structure of Earth's atmosphere now we
know something about this because every
day we launch weather balloons up into
the atmosphere to collect data and
here's an example of one of these
weather balloons at this guy's holding
he's got this whole box here and that
box is called the radiosonde and it's
like a little weather station and that a
records temperature and humidity and
wind and all this kinds of stuff and it
beams it back to earth wirelessly so all
he does is let go of this balloon and it
goes up through the atmosphere and as it
goes up it expands because we said
rising parcels of air always have to
expand and cool well eventually this
will expand so much that it will pop and
this will fall back to earth with a
little parachute now there's a whole
network of airports around the world
that are designated spots to launch
weather balloons and we do it every 12
hours and the reason for this is in
weather forecasting you need to know
what the conditions are up in the upper
part of the atmosphere so it turns out
that Albuquerque's Airport the Sunport
is one of these airports that launches
weather balloons so about five or six in
the morning and five or six in the
evening we'll launch one of these and as
it goes up to the atmosphere it collects
data and here's an example of some data
that was collected as an afternoon on
the July 4th and so this one probably
went up at 5:00 in the afternoon and
here on the x-axis that's air
temperature in the y-axis is height so
the red represents the temperature that
the weather balloon a sensed as it was
ascending up into the atmosphere so here
at the surface you can see before the
weather balloon was let go it was 90
degrees at the surface and as soon as it
was launched the weather balloon noticed
that it whether the air is getting
colder with height and then it gets to
about 50,000 feet and suddenly you
notice that it starts getting warmer
with height this inflection point right
here we talked about
before when we talked about clouds and
how we said that this makes a natural
break between two layers in the
atmosphere this is called the tropopause
and it's a surface between all the air
below which is the troposphere and they
all the air above which is the
stratosphere now we didn't talk to the
time why it gets warmer with height now
in this case what happened is the
weather one popped at about a hundred
thousand feet but if it could have kept
going it would have noticed that it
continued to get warmer with height so
if you could look up in this in the
stratosphere what you would see is there
a small number of these molecules of
what we call ozone which are three
oxygen molecules bonded together oh
three an ozone hangs out there's not
much of it up there but it hangs out in
the in the stratosphere and if
ultraviolet light comes in from the Sun
and UV light is what gives you a sunburn
right so we have UV light here at the
surface but we don't have nearly as much
at the surface as we would at the top of
the atmosphere because when the UV light
comes down through this ozone you know
strike an ozone molecule and it'll break
the ozone into two pieces and o2 and an
O now eventually through a number of
steps these two pieces will come back
together and make a new ozone but when
it breaks it apart two things happen for
one the UV is blocked it doesn't reach
the surface of the earth that's a good
news for us
and number two it releases a little bit
of heat so all of these ozone molecules
floating around up in the stratosphere
are getting whacked with UV radiation
all the time and as a result it's adding
warmth to the stratosphere which is why
the stratosphere actually gets warmer
with height now the amount of UV that
comes in from the upper atmosphere is so
great that we wouldn't actually be able
to exist on the surface if it wasn't for
the ozone layer there's so much
radiation coming from the Sun you're
essentially sterilized the planet so the
amount of UV that gives us sunburns is
just a tiny tiny percent of the amount
of UV
would normally hit the surface if it
wasn't for this ozone layer
so this ozone layer is super beneficial
to not just humans but to all life on
Earth at least everything on the land
but it's actually been declining over
the past several decades so here we have
a couple images of the ozone in the
southern hemisphere and we're looking at
colors that represent how much ozone is
in the stratosphere so the blue
represents very little ozone or as the
greens and yellows that's more ozone
that's the South Pole and you can kind
of make out Antarctica down there so
we've got to mid two images one in 1979
one in 2012 and you can see how it's
more that blue is in the 2012 image this
is what we what we refer to as the ozone
hole is this area kind of centered in
the southern hemisphere where UV
radiation can go right through that and
strike the surface below because there's
very little ozone here now
there's not a lot of people living in
Antarctica so it hasn't been a huge
hazard for human health but this was
discovered in the 1980s and there is a
big worry in that this ozone hole was
going to continue to grow because they
could see it growing and there's a
there's a fear that it would actually
engulf the whole planet and if it did if
we lost the ozone layer you know we
couldn't survive on land so it was a
pretty big deal so scientists started
looking at this in the 1970s and they
realized that there is this family of
molecules that we were manufacturing
called chlorofluorocarbons or CFCs and
they get their name because they have
one at least one atom of chlorine one
atom of fluorine and one atom of carbon
in their molecular structure so here's a
simple one called freon 11 and freon 11
is a type of refrigerant it's supposed
to be inside the guts of a refrigerator
or air-conditioner and as long as it's
in there it's safe but if it ever gets
out and it gets into the atmosphere and
if it makes it way up to the
stratosphere a CFC molecule will attach
itself to an ozone
it'll break it apart and then those two
parts can't actually get back together
like they could if they were broken
apart by UV a single CFC molecule can
destroy thousands of ozone molecules and
back in the day they used CFCs for all
kinds of things so they were a popular
propellant in aerosol cans so if you had
if you bought any kind of anything in a
spray can back in the 70s it had CFCs as
a propellant we use it as refrigerants
and air conditioners it made very nice
cleaning solvents so it was a very
useful family of chemicals that were
being made well by the mid-1980s it was
recognized that the ozone layer was
thinning and there was a formation of
this ozone hole over Antarctica so
people started to panic because they
realized this is a super bad thing to
happen and in 1987 a bunch of countries
got together and foreign what was called
the Montreal Protocol and it's like a
treaty among nations and the agreement
was everybody we need to stop
manufacturing CFCs and the rich
countries agreed to go first and this
continued CFCs and then poorer countries
would discontinue it later on well as
they watch the ozone hole grow and grow
in the 80s and the 90s they got back
together in the 90s a couple more times
and signed a couple new treaties to kind
of speed this whole process up by 2006
the ozone hole is the largest had ever
been and by 2015
finally all of the countries were in on
the you know ending the production of
CFCs so it took 30 years from the time
that they discovered this - when finally
everybody stop making CFCs now just
because they stopped making them doesn't
mean the problems over because a lot of
the CFCs in the atmosphere they'll last
hundreds or thousands of years and a lot
of them haven't even gotten up to the
stratosphere yet but after years of
decline and this is this is a how much
ozone is in that
lair the atmosphere so in the 50s and
60s this is kind of how much ozone
should be up there and we see the
decline start in the 70s and the 80s and
right and here is kind of where people
were panicking and starting those
treaties we see it looks like it kind of
bottomed out here in the mid 90s to 2000
technically right there that's the where
it was the the biggest that was owned
homes the biggest in 2006 but what we
see is that very slowly in the last few
years the ozone is starting to come back
now it's going to take decades maybe 100
years or more for the ozone layer to
come back to the layer to the you know
amounts that it was previously but
because there were these this protocol
because there were these treaties
because the countries came together and
greed this is a worldwide environmental
problem and they agreed to sign the
treaty and they agreed to stick with it
the ozone hole is actually a problem
that we have humans have solved I mean
it hasn't been has been fixed yet but
it's on its way to recovery and this is
a model that we're going to talk about
when we talked about air pollution and
later greenhouse gases is can we get all
the countries together to agree to clean
up the air in to clean up problems that
affect everybody on the planet and not
just the country that's making the
chemicals so we're going to return to
examining these two layers and so far
what we've said is that the troposphere
is characterized by the fact that it
gets cooler with height or as the
stratosphere gets warmer with height we
also said that the stratosphere has
ozone and the troposphere does not now
there's also several other very
important differences notice what
happens with dew point so dew point at
the surface was about 40 degrees and
then you see it goes down down down down
and by the time you get to the
stratosphere the dew points like minus
100 so that's super super dry air most
of the moisture in the atmosphere is
down near the surface okay and in fact
if we look at what's happening in the
troposphere itself it has almost
anything you'd be interested in
regarding whether all the clouds are in
the tropics
here 99% of all the water vapors in the
troposphere everything you think of as
weather is happening in the troposphere
and in fact 75% of all the air molecules
in the entire atmosphere are in the
troposphere now what's the stratosphere
like well some people that have more
expendable than income than I do get
cellphones and by weather balloons
because anybody can buy a weather
balloon and they tie their cell phone to
the weather balloon and they launch it I
think I guess they have some app that
just automatically takes pictures and
then they use like their find your phone
feature to find the phone when it lands
somewhere and so here's a picture taken
in a hundred thousand feet this is how
this is right here where our weather
balloon popped this is what it looks
like notice that the sky is black you
can see the curvature of the earth
if you didn't know any better you just
think you're in space but this is how
little air is actually in the
stratosphere by the time you get up
there this guy is black from lack of air
remember this guy a few years ago he
jumped out of a balloon to set a world
record and he decided to jump out over
New Mexico and when he jumped out he was
at 128 thousand feet which is kind of
roughly right in the middle of the
stratosphere and again in these pictures
it looks like he's in space right black
sky you see the curvature of the earth
looks like he's wearing a spacesuit so
even though when you looking at in a
textbook they will show that the
atmosphere has many layers here's the
troposphere here's the stratosphere and
then above that something called the
mesosphere and above that something kind
of thermosphere it looks like the
atmosphere is pretty thick but by the
time you get up to here where those
pictures were taken it's already so
little air that the sky is black and
like we said 75% of the air is in this
troposphere region so the atmosphere is
not as thick as his diagrams like this
imply most of these layers have very
very little hair in them so this brings
up another point that we haven't really
talked about yet but in a cumulonimbus
we've said that you can have an anvil
and the anvil itself is made of ice but
we haven't really talked about why it is
that the anvil grows in the first place
like why does it why is it flat on top
why doesn't it just keep going up so
here's another anvil from space
so convection is happening here and then
something's causing it to flatten out we
said that this is all ice but why is it
so flat well the reason it's flat is
because the cumulonimbus column is
coming up against the tropopause so warm
air can convict easily in the
troposphere most of the time because
it's getting colder with height so warm
air can rise through air that's getting
colder but up in the stratosphere we
have something called a temperature
inversion what that means is it's
getting warmer with height it's inverted
to what you expect you expect the
atmosphere normally it gets colder with
height the temperature inversion means
it's getting warmer with height well you
can't make warm air rise through air
that's getting warmer so anything that's
convecting anything that's rising from
the surface gets stuck right here at the
tropopause and for our key mule in the
mist that means that's the top so warm
if the conditions are right and we have
unstable air air will convict and it
will rise but when it gets to the
tropopause it will get stuck and it will
spread out right at the tropopause
right underneath the stratosphere so the
stratosphere really acts like a cap it
prevents convection from going any
further up now sometimes if the
conditions are right you can get
temperature inversions and other places
than the stratosphere so right here
there's a tiny little temperature
inversion here's a little temperature
inversion and if I'm sending up a little
plume of warm air it's gonna get stuck
right there okay so this is critical
for air pollution so in other words
let's imagine that we have I really make
another graph like these and our graph
looks like this so the weather balloon
goes up
and it recognizes this kind of pattern
so it recognizes the fact that it got
colder with height and then he got
warmer a little bit and then it got
colder with height and right here
that's our stratosphere up here right
but this right here this thing right
here is a temperature inversion so let's
imagine that we have a city down here
and there's smoke coming out everybody m
nee when the smoke will rise cuz it's
warm but once it hits that inversion
it's going to get stuck and if I have a
whole city and a whole bunch of houses
and a whole bunch of cars and all the
pollution is trapped below this in
temperature inversion and as long as
this temperature inversion stays there
this pollution continues to be trapped
below it so sometimes you can see
something like this where you have
here's rising warm air it's just you
know it's a fire and then it hits a
temperature inversion and bam the smoke
doesn't go above that line here is a
really severe temperature inversion
where it goes right down to the surface
so any pollution that's coming out of
anything a car a house and anything is
stuck right there along the surface of
the ground so what would cause this well
one of the things that causes two
inversions close to the surface is high
pressure so before what we talked about
is that height so this is a slide from a
previous lecture and we said you have
winds aloft that converge and then they
go down and all these things happen
right well the other thing that we could
add to this list from last time is that
we can make temperature inversions if
you make temperature inversions you can
trap pollution down here if you trap
pollution down here you might have very
poor air quality now one day of this no
big deal but you can have high pressure
centers that might be parked over an
area for a week or maybe two weeks or
even more and that starts to make the
air quality
really poor on the other hand if you
have a low pressure it actually cleans
the air out so it's like this giant
vacuum cleaner in the sky and it lifts
up all the air pollution and takes it
away so let me show you a couple of
pictures that show the effect of one of
these temperature inversions so here I
am about 30 miles west of Albuquerque
I'm about 10,000 feet above the ground
and I want you to notice what you can
see in other words notice the detail the
terrain that you can see in here or in
this one right now
a high pressure had started building a
couple days before I took these pictures
and you can see some haze in the
distance but then I went back about two
weeks later and not high pressure had
just stayed there for two weeks and when
I went back and I fluid the same spot at
the same height and I took another
picture in the same spot and notice how
it looks now you can barely tell the
surface is down there right so
definitely you can't see the detail you
saw before what we're looking at is air
pollution that's stuck below an
inversion and you can see from the from
the city this is downtown you can see
that air pollution down here below
trapped below the inversion so sometimes
the inversions can be really striking so
here's one thing Kazakhstan and you can
see right at the top of the inversion
and now the super polluted air that's
below and they're really clean here
that's above so the right there that's
the top of the inversion there now when
you have a city in a valley you can get
inversions and in other ways than the
ways that I've just described what
happens is a cold air can settle in the
bottom of a valley and because it's
dense it stays down there and it forms
an inversion that can last for weeks and
weeks and more locally Salt Lake City
has this problem a lot so down there and
that hay is a Salt Lake City it sits in
this bowl and fills with cold air and
they will have weeks of weather just
like this so here's another image Salt
Lake City you can see the brown above it
so there's that inversion the top of the
inversions about right there and you see
that the tops of the mountains look a
lot cleaner up here that's cleaner air
so this happens a lot in the in Salt
Lake City like weeks and weeks they'll
have this kind of air pollution problems
so if you go back to the last lecture
and look at those pressure maps here's
the first one we looked at and we said
that this is a big ridge of high
pressure not only do we now know that
this is sinking air and that we have
cloudless skies but if this sits over
the western US for days or a couple
weeks we also now know that it's going
to contribute to poor air quality that
is to say that the sinking air is
probably creating a temperature
inversion in here and because of that
these guys may be sitting in in in
pretty poor air quality is a lot of air
pollution so we're going to go through
some of the common air pollutants and
the first one is something called
particulate matter which we just
abbreviate is PM in particulate matter
our physical chunks of things in the
atmosphere so you can see this stuff so
what do you think of a smoke or dust
that haze in the background that's p.m.
and we break p.m. up into two groups
based on the size and this number two
and a half and ten refers to how many
microns in diameter and a micron is a
millionth of a meter and so all we need
to know in this class is that they're
both microscopic but there's one group
that's even tinier than then the other
group so it could be things like pollen
grains or salt grains or dust grains or
bacteria or mold spores all kinds of
things could count as PM and a naturally
common naturally occurring one is that a
pollen and so pollen grains every
species of plant has a slightly
different pollen grain and if you have
allergies then you are allergic to
actually the size of the particle it
turns out
so for example the plants that I'm
allergic to have a certain size and they
may not be the plants that you're
allergic to because you're allergic to a
different size so that's why people are
allergic to different things it all
comes down to that the diameter of the
pollen now dust itself can be made of a
lot of things and it depends on if
you've got inside desk or outside dust
and so an interesting experiment was
conducted one time there's a museum in
Germany and I don't know what they had
but they were real it was something very
valuable and they didn't want it to get
dusty and so they had like double doors
and you had to change your clothes and
all this stuff and they found out they
kept getting dust on the exhibits so
they analyzed it on the microscope and
they found out that most of the dust was
actually dead skin and it turns out
we're all shedding skin all the time and
if you have a sealed indoor environment
and you go up to something and you you
do this on the wind seal and you got
dust on your finger that's most likely
dead skin and that also means that
you're constantly breathing in little
particles of dead skin from other people
because they're floating around in the
air
now that might gross you out but your
body absorbs those skin flakes and it
doesn't hurt you that's better for you
then outside dust because outside dust
is usually a little fragments of rock
and those rock fragments are usually not
soluble in your body so what happens is
you breathe them in and then go into
your lungs and they stay there forever
now here's something called silica dust
so silica is just a it's a group of
minerals rocks and minerals and when we
have dust like in New Mexico the dust
storms the haboobs and all that what
you're seeing mostly is silica dust and
silica dust has sharp edges so this is
bad because you briefed us in it goes
into your lungs it never leaves it web
does itself into your lungs and every
time you breathe it wiggles a little bit
and every time it wiggles and makes scar
tissue and eventually that can lead to
lung cancer this is the same reason that
smokers get lung cancer okay same kind
of idea now
you have in your lungs no matter where
you live you also have some of these
little you have these little tiny
microscopic spheres that are mostly
carbon that come from exhaust a lot of
it comes from diesel engines especially
the older ones but we all have them and
if you were to cut a lung open and look
at it you would see these tiny little
black spheres now they're not black in
this image because this is a scanning
electron microscope so they look white
but if you could see them there are
little spheres of mostly carbon
surrounded by some sulfur surrounded by
some other metals and they're floating
around in the atmosphere and in the air
in all cities so we all have them and
when they do autopsies of people who
live in cities their lungs are dirty
looking because we breathe so much of
this exhaust if patients go into the
hospital and they're on a purifier you
know air purified air for a couple years
their lungs will turn pink so one type
of PM that has a long and sordid history
is that of asbestos asbestos is a
naturally forming mineral this is what
it looks like when it comes out of the
ground and you can it looks kind of
fuzzy here you can peel it into little
fibers so if you did so it would kind of
look like this and those fibers have
some really unique properties and that
for one thing they're fireproof and you
can sew them into different products and
so starting in the 1800's they started
to sew asbestos into fireproof
cloth or fireproof blankets and then
eventually they started putting it in
into your house so they start using it
as insulation your attic fireproof and
in your walls fireproof and all kinds of
different products now today there's
asbestos in your house but it's embedded
in products it's not freely just out in
your your attic like it used to be and
the reason for that is because asbestos
is very hazardous to breathe and so
under a microscope this is a scanning
electron microscope it's asbestos is a
bunch of tiny little needles and when
you breathe them in they
you know these are microscopic you can't
even see them you breathe the man they
go into your lungs
they puncture your lung and they embed
themselves in there and they never leave
so your body cannot dissolve them and so
over time what happens is as you breathe
in and out the little fibers wiggle and
create scar tissue and that's what's
shown here in the red and eventually
this will lead to lung cancer and some
other lung related diseases that are due
to breathing in asbestos fibers so we
have a story in this country about a
town in Montana Libby Montana that was
formed for the purpose of mining
asbestos and asbestos was mined in great
volumes out of Libby we don't really
have any pictures not great pictures of
the mine back in the day but this is
sort of the modern equivalent this is a
bestest mine in Canada there's big
trucks down there for scale so it's a
what we call big pit mine so they had
something similar to this in Montana and
back then they didn't think it was
dangerous and so all this asbestos dust
would go up in the air every single day
and coat the entire town so here's a
picture from the 50s and this white
material you see is asbestos dust
you know the workers would come home
they have asbestos on their clothes and
they brush it off and it's all in the
house and everybody's breathing it and
as a result hundreds of people just in
that town died from asbestos related
lung disease and so there's a whole
bunch of books that have been written
this is just one of them that's recently
been published that detail this this
whole asbestos problem from Libby
Montana thousands of people have serious
chronic health problems because of this
they think as many as 50 million you
know us homes have products from Libby
Montana in them so it would take a long
time to go over the entire history of
everything that's happened regarding
asbestos bill I'm gonna hit a few of the
high points here because the story of
asbestos gets repeated for other things
in our country later on so early
eighteen
we get the first US patent for asbestos
and a company by the name of Johns
Manville is formed and Johns Manville
still around today they make insulation
for your house and by the late
18-hundreds were mining lots of asbestos
in this country and making things out of
it by 1906 there's a doctor who starts
to notice that anybody that works with
asbestos seems to die early died
prematurely and he publishes a paper
about this and more studies are done and
by 1918 insurance companies recognize
this is a real threat and they're
refusing to sell health insurance to
people that work with asbestos and by
1922 the US Navy recognizes that it's
hazardous requires people to wear
respirators ok so we can establish that
by the early 1900's it's already known
that asbestos is hazardous to human
health ok but we continue to mine in
this country and so as time goes on
there's more and more studies about
workers that fall ill due to asbestos
and let's see we get to the 1930s some
other countries start to pass rate laws
regulating asbestos use not in this
country
in 1936 johns manville that's the
company that's mining this stuff higher
is an independent group to do research
to see you know is this really hazardous
material and these independent group of
scientists study and they come back and
they say yeah it's really hazardous and
so the executives decide to suppress
those studies so they aren't released
and then like a similar incident happens
a few years later we're where another
group studies the effect of asbestos on
mice and they found on 80% of the mice
inhaled asbestos get cancer that
research also not published case so
we're gonna see this is also going to be
a common theme we're gonna see in this
class on some other topics and let's see
we've got more studies come out here's
one of note in 1960 that they realized
that not just the people that work with
asbestos but their family members were
getting sick other children were getting
our residents in the town that you know
didn't have anybody in the immediate
family that even worked with asbestos
we're getting sick so they realize it's
a much broader problem and finally when
we get to the early 70s it's finally
listed it listed in this country as a
hazardous air pollutant and this is the
first time in this country we finally
recognize that there's something wrong
with asbestos India shouldn't breathe it
realize that this is coming like 60
years after the first papers were
published in them in the medical science
so from then from that point forward
Congress has tried to pass more
legislation to try to restrict how much
asbestos one can can breathe and be
exposed to and so let's see there's a
bunch of several things here but as time
goes on there are more and more laws
being passed regulating the the use in
the the mining of asbestos now in 1991 a
bunch of manufacturers of asbestos got
together and challenged the EPA the
Environmental Protection Agency in court
and they got them throw out some of the
rules regarding asbestos okay so the
companies that are mining this stuff are
are fighting against these regulations
so as time goes by though eventually the
regulations win in 2002 we finally stop
mining asbestos in California now we're
about a hundred years past when the the
first studies were shown that it's a
very dangerous thing to breathe and I
kind of skip a bunch of these but in
2010 there was a study that that said
that between in a 10-year period between
2000 and 2010 forty three thousand four
hundred sixty four Americans died from
diseases related to the inhalation of
asbestos okay just in that ten years so
these are people that had been exposed
like in the past and that's finally
catching up to them by 2013 fifty
countries have banned asbestos but us is
not one of them and this reveals kind of
a
problem in our political system which is
that the asbestos industry has a lot of
lobbyists they put a lot of money into
the political system to fight some of
these regulations and we've seen the
effect of this finally if we jump ahead
so as the years go by we're mining less
and less asbestos in this country per
year so the latest number I can find
2015 about 360 tons of asbestos in the
United States each year it's not zero
but point is this is a material that was
deemed hazardous early 1900s and over a
hundred years later there are still
people being exposed to it and a big
reason for that is lobbyist money big
money gets into the government you can
affect politicians votes and keep things
legal that are actually hazardous to
health so this isn't to say that other
countries are doing a better job
necessarily so here's a modern asbestos
mine in China all that white material
you see there that's all asbestos fibers
and in fact here's some asbestos mining
in India these guys just wear a scarf
around their mouth that's their
respirator or like this guy he's got a
handkerchief I have no idea how many
fibers they're breathing in but I don't
know how you know we don't know how long
these guys are going to live but they're
currently being exposed so as a side
note the fact that we have millions of
buildings in this country with asbestos
in them sparked a new industry called
the asbestos abatement industry which is
that a company will go into a building
usually it's a private building like a
school or a hospital something like that
and they will pull all the asbestos out
of all the places that it was originally
put in you know as insulation and it's a
very expensive process so here what
they're doing is they're pulling out the
asbestos that used to be up here in
these joists and you know all dressed up
in their bunny suits and etc and what's
in these bags are these easy the
asbestos fibers that they're removing
well one of the problems of doing this
is that once the asbestos is in the
building
and behind the walls and nobody's
messing with it it's really not that bad
but when you go and you start digging it
out you raise all kinds of asbestos
fibers again and it's been shown that
asbestos abatement probably just makes
the problem worse it's not really
necessary and the act of going in there
and doing that raises a lot of asbestos
dust so some people have argued that
this is totally unnecessary but now this
is an industry that has a lot of money
behind it and it keeps on going so we're
going to look at p.m. on earth little
Schoolnet and the way I do that is I
click the word earth and I click on
particulates and this is going to show
me a lot of the PM that's in the air
today and I can look around and I can
see that there's some swirls of
particulate matter across the United
States I can look around the world and
there's a bunch usually in China which
we're kind of seeing here they've got a
lot of you know a lot of smoke but
notice what's happening over here and so
this is Africa and in the northern part
of Africa there's this huge plume of PM
and if you can notice this but the wind
well you can't see it so much today but
the wind is blowing it off the continent
and it's headed across the ocean you
also see it over here in the Middle East
so normally on a normal day the most PM
you will see on earth is here northern
Africa in the Middle East now why is
that so this is actually naturally
occurring for the most part North Africa
is very dry and when so this is the
Sahara Desert and wind blows dust off
the continent into these big plumes that
go across the ocean so these winds are
called the easterlies they're bringing
dust across the ocean and it'll actually
land over here in South America now this
is important because South America right
here this is the Amazon rainforest right
and so one of the problems with rain
forests is because they rain so much
there's almost no soil the soil
dissolves away
from all the rain it's really hard to
maintain soil what you need to maintain
rain forests in a place where it rains a
lot well here what's happening is very
slowly over time dust is blown off the
continent from Africa it travels all the
way across the ocean and it falls out
over South America and very slowly adds
to the floor of the rain forests so in a
way the dust from Africa is fertilizing
the rain forests of South America
so that's p.m. now we can also break it
down further and we can look at say p.m.
two and a half and we can see a few more
details you can you can see particulates
coming from different sources some of
these are fires some of these are cities
with there's a lot of smoke that's
probably Mexico City right there if you
go to say South America we see these
spots those are probably all fires in
Central Africa so there's the the Sahara
dust but we see a lot of dust from fires
from slash-and-burn practices that we'll
talk about more in a second and look at
India and look at China a lot of air
pollution in the particulates here and
most of that is just industrial you know
people burning things that's what most
of that is so the next flute and on our
list is VOCs which stands for volatile
organic compound now volatile in this
case means it evaporates fairly easily
organic doesn't mean it comes from whole
foods it means that it's made of carbon
and that's just a different use of the
word organic compound it has several
atoms in it now it turns out that our
nose and brain are set up that we can
smell most VOCs here's an example
acetone so acetone there this is what
the chemical structure looks like there
is your carbon so that's why it's called
organic and ladies you know this as
fingernail polish remover you know when
as soon as you remove the lid super
stinky right that's a vo see
things like gasoline paint those are all
VOCs and usually you can smell them
quite easily now most of the VOCs that
we have in the air here in New Mexico
come from the gas and oil fields so a
lot of times what happens is that we
royal forms it rises to these natural
pockets in the crust so this is called
an anticline now the gas will often
accumulate at the top of the pocket and
the oil is a little bit below that so if
they're drilling they might be drilling
to get the gas on purpose and sometimes
when that happens some of it gets out
and gets into the atmosphere sometimes
they're after the oil and the gases are
just kind of in the way either way a lot
of times the gas leaks out and gets into
the atmosphere so here's a pumpjack so
it's job is to pump petroleum which is a
liquid but if you've been by one of
these there's an odor in the air and a
lot of what you're smelling or VOCs
there's natural gas coming out of this
well a little bit here's a natural gas
well so they've dug a hole and they
basically did is put in a valve and
natural gas comes out of this pipe and
then it goes on to a processing plant
but there's also natural gas kind of
seeping out of the ground around where
this well was built
now once natural gas comes out of the
ground they can't just directly sell it
to you for your gas stove they've got a
it's got to go through a few steps it's
got to be purified and clean separate it
out into different components sometimes
and then they got to compress it and
they push it down a pipe so maybe
there's a gas what you know one of these
over like Carlsbad and then the way it
gets to Albuquerque is there's an
underground pipe that takes it all the
way from Carlsbad to Albuquerque and so
a gas plant is kind of the first stage
in that where they separate out the
different components and purify it and
then in order to get it all the way to
Albuquerque down the pipe they've got to
compress it in several different places
along the way those are called gas
compressor stations and each one of
these a little bit is lost
in in the atmosphere and in the gas
plants and the gas compressor stations
and then a lot of times again if they're
after oil and they don't want the gas
they still have to do something with it
so a lot of times they'll just burn it
that's called flaring so what's
happening here is they're trying to get
petroleum but they also got some gas
that came out with it but it's not worth
the effort and the money to try to you
know compress it and clean it all that
so they just rather burn it so that also
emits some VOCs into the atmosphere also
some PM there's a lot of PM in in in
these black clouds here then another
source of vo C is the refinery so
refineries are where we take petroleum
and we basically put it under vessels of
pressure and heat and we separate out
we're all petroleum oil crude oil into
the different components so gasoline
diesel kerosene all those things come
from crude petroleum but they have to be
processed in a refinery to make those
products and so in that process a lot of
VOCs are emitted to the atmosphere and
in New Mexico we have a couple
refineries one you may have been exposed
to is in Artesia if you've ever been
through the town of Artesia it has a
particular odor and what you're smelling
or VOCs and they're coming from this
refinery so the Navajo refinery is
official name of this and it's right in
the middle of town you drive right by it
and you can smell it
those are VOCs moving on to our next
pollutant is sulfur dioxide and sulfur
is in a lot of fossil fuels so when you
burn fossil fuels so2 is a common
byproduct he burned coal you burn
gasoline you burn diesel you produce
sulfur now one of the problems is that
sulfur by itself isn't quite that
harmful but once it gets into the
atmosphere you know combined with water
molecules and form sulfuric acid that
sulfuric acid that's floating around in
the atmosphere then condenses to form
rain and you get
Sidda crane so here is some clouds that
are forming here's a plume of sulfur
dioxide that's actually forming clouds
that are acidic so these so we know that
cumulus clouds don't rain but if they
were to produce rain you get very acidic
rain coming out of these clouds now acid
rain
used to be a really big deal and today
our big environmental problem is global
warming in the 80s it was the ozone hole
you go back 100 years it was acid rain
acid rain stresses vegetation so the
branch on the Left has been exposed to
acidic rain and you can see it's not not
doing so well in fact when in in the
late 1800s people started burning lots
of coal in steam engines and then
eventually people started produce
electricity there's a lot of coal being
burned and producing a lot of sulfur it
went out into the atmosphere made a lot
of acid rain and there are entire swaths
of forests in Europe that were killed
because of acid rain and you can still
see them today they're starting to come
back but there are places where there's
just millions of acres of dead trees
from acid rain and most of this occurred
in the late 1800s Early 1900s another
thing that happens is that acid rain
reacts with limestone and marble and
dissolves it so here's a marble statue
that was carved in 1702 and 1908
this is what it looks like so it's been
around 200 years at this point
1968 notice that it looks like someone
just took an eraser to it and acid rain
basically dissolved away this statue and
we've lost a lot of statues worldwide to
acidic rain here's another example this
is something called an obelisk it's made
out of limestone and it's from Egypt and
it was carved out of limestone about
3,000 years ago and you can see the
hieroglyphics in this old picture this
is what it looked like in 1884
there was a point in history where it
was okay for cities just go to Egypt and
take things and so New York City just
decided hey that would be cool to have
that in Central Park so they took it and
they put it in Central Park and you'll
notice that a lot of the hieroglyphics
are not recognizable anymore in fact
this is what it looks like up close it
has this kind of pockmarked texture
acid rain dissolved away a lot of the
hieroglyphics in that 3000 year old
obelisk and it just happened within like
you know a hundred years so we're going
to return now to earth nil Schoolnet and
we're gonna look for sulfur so I click
the word earth in under mode I'm going
to chem and then under overlay at so2
okay so now the colors represent sulfur
dioxide emissions and if i zoom in here
across the US I can see a whole bunch of
little red dots with tails every one of
those is a coal-fired power plant
including some here in New Mexico so
coal has sulfur in it and in this
country coal-fired power plants are
required to remove at least some of the
sulfur out of the the exhaust but some
of it still gets into the atmosphere and
that's what all these red dots are so in
the eastern part of the country there's
a whole lot more Coal Fired power plants
than there are in the West so we see a
lot more sulfur emissions out there but
let's look around the world here
how much happening in Africa but oh boy
look at China so China has a lot of
coal-fired power plants and they don't
have the emission regulations that we do
so they emit a lot more sulfur than we
do and you can see on here there's just
a bright purple blob
you know India's got a fair amount -
right but China really has most of the
sulfur emissions right now also you
might notice let's see if we can find it
here's some
see these stripes like that stripe right
there it goes across the ocean here's
another one that's stripe do you know
why there might be stripes of sulfur out
in the ocean so those stripes of sulfur
dioxide that are out in the ocean
those are shipping lanes and out in the
ocean there are these giant container
ships just about anything you've ever
bought has been on a container ship at
some point in its life and these things
are out in the ocean they're enormous
they have giant engines and they burn
really cheap fuel that has a lot of
sulfur in it the reason they can get
away with this is because out in the
open ocean there's no pollution laws
when you're 200 nautical miles from the
shoreline then the the country in
question there air pollution laws apply
but on the rest of the ocean there's no
loss and so these big container ships
really pollute and put it in perspective
15 of these big container ships produced
as much so2 as all of the cars in the
world combined okay and then figure well
there's 6,000 of those giant container
ships out in the ocean right now and
85,000 commercial ships that are
currently in use so there's a lot of air
pollution out in the ocean from these
giant ships next one on our list is
oxides of nitrogen which we abbreviate
as knocks knocks are two different
molecules n o and no2 you get them when
you burn fuel at high temperatures so
for example a car engine burns gasoline
at pretty high temperature it produces
NOx and when you if you live in an area
where you have to get your car emissions
tested NOx is one of the things that
they're testing for well one of the
problems with NOx is that it combines
with atmospheric water vapor to produce
an acid in the similar way that sulfur
does except instead of sulfuric acid it
produces something called nitric acid
and this also contributes to acid rain
ozone so we've talked about ozone in the
stratosphere and we say this is
wonderful marvelous thing that protects
us down here from UV gotta have it
however there's a second source of ozone
that's not natural it's down here at the
surface and it's really really bad for
you pure oxygen o2 is an oxidizing
compound o 3 is an especially oxidizing
compound if you breathe in o 3 it
attacks all the tissues in your body and
it's a major lung irritant and the way
you get ozone at the surface is if you
have VOCs + NOx in the presence of
sunlight those three things will react
for to produce ozone so some big cities
especially those that have you know
temperature inversions like we've been
talking about they'll issue ozone
warnings and basically don't go outside
because the ozone is so bad now in
Albuquerque we don't really have that
problem here we don't have enough air
pollution that ozone really ever becomes
an issue but some cities everyday
there's some sort of ozone reading or
ozone warning that gets a community
communicated to the public
carbon monoxide next on our list
carbon monoxide is sometimes often
confused with co2 okay CO vs. co2 two
different things
carbon monoxide like almost everything
we've been talking about here is a
product of burning feel so carbon
monoxide you can't see it you can't
smell it but it's poisonous and what
happens is normally when you breathe in
oxygen oxygen goes into your bloodstream
it finds a red blood cell it attaches to
a certain place in the red blood cell
there's some electrons exchanged and
then it leaves as a carbon dioxide okay
carbon monoxide comes in finds that spot
on your red blood cell attaches itself
and stays there and so that red blood
cell no longer
can operate as a red blood cell and so
as you breathe in carbon monoxide what
happens is all the receptors in your red
blood cells become choked with these
carbon monoxide molecules now your
experience is you start to get sleepy
right so what's happening is you're
slowly become becoming suffocated and
eventually is also sleepy able to take a
nap and you never wake up that's carbon
monoxide poisoning
so people that commit suicide by
breathing car exhaust in the garage
what's actually killing them is the
carbon monoxide okay it's coming out of
all car exhaust so we're going to go to
earth Donnell Schoolnet and look at some
carbon monoxide so mode is still kim
overlay I'm changing the co and now the
bright spots are plumes of carbon
monoxide it looks like here we maybe got
some fires that's probably just
automobile exhaust from New York City
automobile exhaust from LA Chicago let's
look down here okay so here we are in
South America and there's this cluster
of these plumes of carbon monoxide every
one of those dots and these are fires
and these are fires started by humans
because what we're looking at is what we
call slash and burn agriculture so
Americans like hamburgers hamburgers
come from cows and if you want to grow
cows in another country you can't do it
in rainforests so cows like grass so
what they do is they chop down the
rainforests and they burn it and then
they grow grass but as we said a few
minutes ago there's not much soil in the
rainforest
so grass doesn't last very long so you
get a couple seasons of grass out of it
and then the cows need to move on so you
got to chop more rainforests down and
repeat the process so this is all
agriculture practices here mostly it's a
grow cattle to sell to us in fact if we
look over here in Africa okay we got
some
more over here so each one of these
little spots is a place where those it's
a fire do the slash and burn for the
most part so let's see here
there's India Oh China he never failed
disappoint so a lot of carbon monoxide
emissions from China today so again
that's you know mostly it's all from
burning fuel so whether that's
coal-fired power plants or automobiles
or factories or something that's what's
causing it so it looks like today the
world record holder for C Co emissions
is China once again so next up on our
list of air pollutants are the heavy
metals lead which is pretty soft and
mercury which is liquid at room
temperature it may not make sense that
you could have heavy metals in the air
but there's a couple ways that could
happen with lead he used to be that lead
was in gasoline and they put it in
gasoline because it was a cheap way of
raising the octane level and so for 75
years or so
we burned lead gasoline in our cars and
all that lead went out into the
atmosphere so much so that there's
really almost no place you can go on
earth now and not find lead in the soil
so in the 80s we started to phase out
leaded gasoline so for a while you could
buy regular gas which meant it had lead
in it and then the unleaded and then
about a decade after that they got rid
of the leaded gasoline altogether and
your only choice now is unleaded at
least for cars in this country what also
was in all paint it forms compounds
they're very colorful so they used to
use lead to make the pigment and so what
would happen is they would paint a house
with lead-based paint and then the paint
would chip off over time and flutter
away into the wind and you could get led
into the atmosphere that way so and the
recent year or so Flint Michigan has
been in the news about the lead in their
water but there's actually a lot of
places that have
led problems and this map you can
explore if you want and you can find
where you live and it'll tell you how
much lead is in the environment
if you zoom zoom in on Albuquerque you
see there's a lot of red zones here
around Albuquerque and these are
neighborhoods most of these are
neighborhoods that were built with
lead-based paint including the house
that this is being recorded in so this
has led all over the environments in the
water in the paint in the soil whatever
right now we're talking about lead as an
air pollutant only now mercury can also
get into the air because it's naturally
occurring in coal so here's a coal-fired
power plant there's a big pile of coal
there they're going to burn and in an
earlier lecture we talked about how
water vapor condenses out to make a
little cloud that's from burning
hydrocarbons in the coal but what's also
coming out of the chimney is mercury and
so every coal-fired power plant is
putting a little bit of mercury into the
atmosphere now mercury ends up in the
ecosystem and can get concentrated in
certain organisms like fish so somehow
or another the biology of fish is such
that mercury gets concentrated in fish
tissues and there's places where the
fish have so much mercury that you can't
eat the fish
so mercury is a neurotoxin it causes
brain cancer among other things and so
if you eat fish it's wise to pick fish
that don't eat other fish okay so for
example a big fish that are predators
that eat other fish they end up with
more mercury in their bodies it gets
concentrated in their bodies you're
healthier fish are the ones that don't
eat other fish but maybe eat insects or
something like that so your salmon
steelhead etc those are healthier fish
this is especially true if you're
pregnant so if you think you're pregnant
don't eat tuna okay
because tuna has measure amounts of
mercury in it so a lot of people may not
realize this but a lot of the big
American cities went through a period of
time where the air pollution got so bad
that they're almost uninhabitable
and these pictures are from the 40s 50s
and 60s of some cities like Los Angeles
in San Francisco New York and what looks
like fog is actually air pollution and
it became really unpleasant to live
there
you know everybody's eyes are burning
you couldn't see the buildings it was
really not pleasant to be outside and so
finally Congress decides to do something
about it starting in the 50s and it
starts out with something called the air
pollution control act and it really
didn't do much by today's standards it
gave the Surgeon General permission to
distribute information about air
pollution like that's a big nothing but
baby steps okay and then 1963 they
established something called the clean
air act and this is going to at first
doesn't have any teeth really but it's
going to grow in later years and at
first all it does is it establishes a
federal program to study air pollution
but so far people can still pollute as
much as they want in fact here's a
picture from 1970 this is a battery
processing plant big plumes of black
acrid smoke going out in the atmosphere
completely legal there's no laws
regarding air pollution at that point
now in the 1960s there's there's going
to be some laws that start to come into
effect regarding air pollution with cars
so the first amendment to the Clean Air
Act occurs in 1965 called the motor
vehicle Air Pollution Control Act and
what it said is that cars that are going
to start being built in 1968 have to be
cleaner than the previous models that
compared to a 1963 car have to emit 72
percent less VOCs and 56 percent less
carbon monoxide okay so that's the very
first time there's a law regarding air
pollution with cars so prior to 1968
cars could put as much as they wanted
there was no laws regarding that well a
lot of things are happening in the late
sixties early seventies regarding air
pollution in fact regarding pollution in
general there is this sort of
environmental movement afoot and people
were protest
thing about the quality the poor quality
of the air so here's some photos from
from those times and there's a bunch of
Luther laws or kind of being passed but
in 1970 the established Environmental
Protection Agency so this is an agency
that's designed to be in charge of all
these environmental problems ok so prior
to 1970 there are a bunch of the laws
some regarding air some with water or
some with wildlife and they were taken
up by different agencies and and the EPA
was supposed to head all of those things
okay
consolidate all those different laws so
that happens in 1970 then the same year
there are amendments to that Clean Air
Act the one that they started in 1963
and this is where they introduced the
list of pollutants that we've been
talking about p.m. VOCs so2 these are
things that now can be regulated for the
first time ever all right and this law
becomes amended in the future so there's
amendments in 1977 those amendments in
1990 and what happens throughout time is
that more and more air pollutants are
added to the list so we went over some
one that the big ones right so2 carbon
monoxide those things as time has gone
on more pollutants have been added to
the list and more regulations about how
much you're allowed to emit into the
atmosphere well as a result of this so
here's a graph starts in 1980 goes to
the year 2013 and it's got a bunch of
things on here but this Green Line is
the the big pollutants that we've talked
about okay VOCs p.m. all those things
they've gone down since 1980 to 2013 by
62% so there's 62% less of those
emissions going into the air compared to
1980 during that same time we have more
people we have more cars
we're traveling more miles we're using
more electricity so even though there's
more of us driving more owning more cars
the amount of actual air pollution has
been going down
and this is because of the Clean Air Act
another way you can measure this are in
the amount of smoggy days so this is in
the Bay Area so near San Francisco and
they were keeping track of how many days
of really hazardous smog that they had
so this is 1969 and you can see they've
gotten you know someone who looks like
about 65 days of really extreme smog and
over time you know there's good years
and bad years but they start to hit days
with zero days of really intense smog
and again this is due to the Clean Air
Act there's more people there today
there's more cars there today
that their air is actually been getting
cleaner and you can see photographs of
this this is LA 1968 versus LA 2005
right so the Clean Air Act and these
these rules actually had a big impact
cars have been getting cleaner and
cleaner every year so every couple years
manufacturers have been required to
produce automobiles that pollute less
and less you may not know this but there
are machines that will be set up on the
side of the road that will measure the
pollution of your car we don't really
use them so much in New Mexico but they
do this in California and this is data
from Phoenix so what they're looking for
is their so car drives by and it's
measuring the pollution of the car that
just drove by right that's what it's
measuring so it's measuring vo C and NOx
and there's three different kinds of
cars here SUV's pickups small cars or
sorry small pickups and then just cars
and what you notice from 1981 to 1999
that the amount of VOCs are going down
in the amount of NOx going down okay and
so that again that's due the regulation
from the Clean Air Act manufacturers are
required to meet these certain standards
for air pollution so without making
things political we have to talk about
making things political because we're in
a very weird time and I don't know when
you're going to watch this but I'm
recording this in early 2008 and we've
had the Trump administration now for a
year
and things are changing things are
chaotic
so without diving too deep into it let's
talk about a couple of things if you
took this class ten years ago we would
talk about the Clean Air Act we talked
about the rules every year things are
getting better every year the air is
getting cleaner right but now
everything's in flux and so one of the
things that's happened is a Trump has
appointed Scott Pruett in charge of the
EPA well Scott Pruett is has nothing to
do with the environment in fact his
background is that he was a lawyer who
is suing the EPA prior prior to this on
behalf of oil and gas companies so his
big thing is he would like the EPA to go
away he was suing kind of like to get
rid of these air pollution laws and now
he's in charge of it right this is a
classic political move if your political
party doesn't like a certain agency you
take someone else that hates that agency
and you put them in charge of it okay so
this is not new okay this kind of thing
has been going on a long time but one of
the things this brings up is well okay
so what's going to happen to all these
air pollution laws right and the answer
is we're not totally sure but about a
year ago
Trump signs an executive order to
quote-unquote initiate a review of the
air pollution policies and they have
been promising the Trump administration
in general has been promising that
they're going to remove a lot of these
air pollution regulations now as of
right now nothing really concrete has
been done they've rolled back a few
things for coal-fired power plants but
they really haven't completely got rid
of the laws that we've been talking
about for the Clean Air Act but or one
year in so I have no idea what's gonna
happen I don't want to dwell on this too
much except to say times are changing
and it's a little ironic that I just
showed you pictures of this from the
1960s and now I can show you the same
pictures of this from 2017 so people
protesting about the exact same thing
forty years later well one of the things
that came out of the Clean Air Act is
something called the AQI
and the AQI is the air quality index and
what it does is it establishes a
monitoring system for air and so we have
a machine that collects air it measures
the air pollution and then it rates it
it's numerical from 0 to 500 and if
you're in the 0 to 50 zone that's
considered good that's where you want
your air most of the time 50 to 100
moderate and so on and so forth all the
way to hazardous which is 300 to 500 and
they assign a color to this as well well
you can go online and you can check the
air quality all across the country and
here's this website right here we're
going to go to this right now
so here's what this website looks like
and we can visually just kind of look at
the quality of the air so we see a lot
of green and yellow that's good news and
you can zoom in and click on any station
to get a reading so if I click on this
one Santa Fe Airport okay so it's
reporting 34 that's that's good right
that's pretty clean air and by and large
we're doing pretty well I don't know
what's going on here we've got some near
the border of 500 that's bad if we go
down to Mexico looks like we've got some
pretty polluted air down here by Mexico
City that's not too surprising and let's
go across the world here so over Europe
here looks like we got a batch a pretty
bad air right in there might be related
to a temperature inversion I'm not
really sure let's keep going no China
does not look good so we got a lot of
red and we have a lot of dark red and in
fact if you look at these if you can
read it says 999 that means that
pollution is so bad it's clear
the scale so when they invented the AQI
scale I only went from 0 to 500 and
there are air pollution monitors in
China that routinely report air
pollution over a thousand in fact the
government isn't completely forthcoming
with how bad the air quality there is
but we have an embassy in China and we
have an air monitor on the roof and so
we we actually know how bad it is and
it's routinely like 1,500 on the AQI
scale something like that
so in fact China is a pretty interesting
study and what happens if you don't have
any air quality regulations so this is
called a sunny day in China and this is
not fog this is air pollution and this
is the kind of air when you have an AQI
of 999 this is what it looks like okay
and it comes in like a fog and it's
often this way for weeks at a time in
Beijing and people walk around with dust
masks on
sometimes people exercise out outside
with with dust masks on other times a
students exercise inside okay these guys
going on the marathon with their
respirators on these guys are pretty
gangster they don't care they're gonna
breathe it in anyway this is what a
satellite picture of China often looks
like all this brown that you see that's
all air pollution so it's worth pointing
out that the one of the reasons the air
pollution is so bad in China is that
unlike us they don't have or have not
historically had any laws regarding air
pollution they've also been growing
they've been putting up like several
coal fire power plants per week in the
last several years but unlike here where
we have a lot of fairly strict
regulations regarding air pollution
they've just pretty much let people do
whatever they want and so you can kind
of see the result of that system here in
fact 2015 they were going to have a
parade to celebrate the in a World War
two so for a couple weeks leading up to
the parade
they took cars off the streets they shut
down power
plans to shut down factories and the day
of the parade or the day before the
parade I guess it is this is what it
looked like this is what Beijing looked
like you can actually see the sky
literally the day after the parade they
are all right back to work everybody
this is what it looked like okay so they
could have clean air it's it's possible
but they're gonna have to invest you
know time energy and political will to
clean up their air to keep it you know
kind of like what we have here so to
summarize the atmospheres have divided
into layers with the lowest two layers
being the troposphere and above that the
stratosphere and the stratosphere has a
big temperature inversion and that's
what blocks convection now high pressure
centers can create temperature
inversions lower down in the troposphere
and if you have one it will prevent
things from convecting and going up into
the atmosphere and that is what traps
air pollution so we went through the
different pollutants and we talked about
how legally nothing really happened in
this country till the 1970s and then we
started passing laws regarding air
pollution and the only things that are
Putin are things that are actually
dangerous to us so as we'll talk about
in a future lecture greenhouse gases are
not part of this list that's a separate
thing and up until a year ago with a new
administration the story has been that
each year that goes by air pollution
here in this country gets better and
better and the restrictions become
tighter and tighter so your cars are
cleaner your factories are cleaner etc
right now who knows what's going to
happen alright thanks for listening
you